Aurudubillahi mina shaytan ar-rajim bismillah rahman ar-rahim Alhamdulillahi sane ilkhalqi ala'atmali nizam wa ahsani kawam Alwade ala sha'ifi ajdari maqam wa arfaqi masaam Alhamdulillahi aadha khalqihi wa zinatul arshihi wa middadu kalimatihi wa muntaha 'ilmihi wa jameer ma sha'a wa khalaka wabaraa
Wahuaalimul Gaibi wa Shahadah ar-Rahmanur-Raheen al-Malik al-Quddu sal-Aziz al-Hakim Wa salatu wa salamu 'alal muayyid Ablig al-Kalam Muhammadin al-Mabrooth sallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam Lihidaya ti kaffati anam ila subul salam wa ilam madallayali walayam
Alladhi arsalahu Allahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-Haq li yuzhirahu aladdin qulli wa kafabillahi shaheedah Wa nashadu an la ilaha illallahu wahbahula sharikalah Wa nashadu anna Muhammadana Abduhu wa Rasulu wa nashadu anna Mawlana Aliyan wasiyahu wa waziru Fa sallallahu alayhim wa ila alayhim wa salli muhum tasliman kathiran kathira
Allahumma la ilmalana illa ma al-lamtana inna kaantal ali mulhakeem Allahumma al-limna bima yanfa'na wa yanfa'na bima al-lamtana Allahumma atina nufusina taqwaha wa zakkana fa'antah khairuman zakkaha Anta waliyuna wa mawlana wa ni'amal mawla wa ni'aman nasir wala hawla wala kuwata illa billahil ali lazim
Faammabaad Yaqulo subhana wa taalafi kitabahil kareem bada akula audubillahi mina shaytana regime bismillahir Rahmano Rahim Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yesterday Amri Wahlulo okdatam millisani yafkahu kawli Allahum masabit naindal maltipila ilaha illallah wallahummaju alamina ladina amanu amil salihat watawasa bil haq watawasa bisabr Amin ya Rabbil Alameen once again salam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu
Alhamdulillah, today I have the honor of speaking about the beloved of Allah.
He was Habibullah, the beloved of Allah.
His name is Muhammad .
The name Muhammad comes from the root word Hamd, which means praise and gratitude.
And Muhammad is the one who is constantly praised.
and who is worthy of eternal gratitude.
And so, just as Allah is Rabbul Alameen, the master of everything in existence, His messenger is Rahmatul Lil Alameen.
He is a mercy for everything in existence.
So everything that Allah is the rub of, He is a mercy for.
And He is the one whose love Allah has made a prerequisite for His own love.
In that we cannot claim the love of Allah without loving His beloved Messenger.
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
Scholars say that Muhabbah or love for most human beings, it arises out of three things.
The first they say is physical love.
You see something beautiful, your heart inclines towards them, right?
Your eyes delight in it.
If you see a human being that is physically beautiful, you can fall in love.
It can happen just from sight.
And the Ulama have maintained the physical description of our Prophet SAW which is the description of a very handsome man.
The second type of love comes from when you hear about the beautiful qualities of a person.
So there is outward beauty, and then there is inward beauty, which is , which is what I have the honor of sharing with you today.
The third type of love, they say, is what you feel for someone who has done good for you, or that you find out that somebody made a sacrifice for you.
So when someone does something good to a decent human being, they love them more and more for that reason.
But when good is done to an ingrate, he resents that person because it generates an envy in his heart.
They begin to feel indebted and they do not like that feeling of being indebted.
So they begin to use strategies within themselves to not feel indebted to that person and these are sick people.
This is why the hypocrites, the Munafiqun are the sickest people and they are rightfully in the lowest place in the eyes of Allah.
Because human hearts by nature love those who do good to them.
If somebody does good for you and then you do not have love for them in return, it's because the heart is not in a natural state, it's in a diseased state.
And if you knew what the Prophet did for you, you would just naturally fall in love with him.
And he did not just do it for you or for, you know, certain people.
He did it for the entire humanity.
His concern was not just for his companions or his family.
You know, most human beings were just concerned.
You know, we have limited concerns.
Our concern is
Limited to why for children husband family at the most extended family Right some people their concern is the community They care about the poor people in the community.
They want to find them and help them because Ultimately the love has to do with the heart That's where love resides right the bigger the heart the more capacity for love and the smaller the heart
the lower the capacity for love.
And our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam had the heart that was concerned for the entire humanity, for generations to come.
He was concerned for animals.
In the Sharia, he gave us guidelines on how to treat animals with kindness.
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
Learning about the Prophet Seera, his life story, is one of the most beautiful things there is to learn.
And this information is readily available in books and on the internet.
I mean, you can look that up.
I would love to speak about it, but for the want of time, I'm just limiting my session to just talk about some of the salient features of his life and share with you what an incredible man he was.
And so I want to focus today's session on Akhlaq.
Inshallah, if Allah gives me an opportunity, someday I would love to just do a session on his physical description, which is quite incredible.
Anyway, so today I want to focus this talk on his character, the Akhlaq.
The word Akhlaq comes from the root word , which means to create.
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala is Khaliq, He is the creator, and we are Makhluq, we are the creation.
We are...
Allah is the Khaliq, He is the creator, and we are the Makhluq, we are the created beings.
We are comprised of a body and a spirit that animates that body, right?
Our material form, the material form of our body is the .
And the spiritual form of our soul is the .
It's the same three letters.
The body is nourished by the physical world, which is food and drink.
Our spirits are nourished by knowledge, by character, which is the plural form of the word .
So, the or the represents our physical existence, whereas represents our spiritual existence.
And they both begin with the letter .
Interestingly, the letter in Arabic is a sound of friction.
It's a sound, they say it's a sound of effort, even when you articulate it, right?
So if you look at any word in the Arabic language that begins with the letter ha, you'll see it is either harsh in its nature or it requires effort.
So for instance, , which is service, servitude, right?
begins with ha and it requires effort.
friendship requires effort.
Fear, it's a harsh emotion.
Khayal, imagination, it requires effort to build.
So you have Khalq and you have Khulq, both starting with the letter Kha.
Why?
Because the body takes effort to develop and so does character.
Character takes a lot of effort to develop.
When we die,
our fully developed body returns back into the earth and our soul with its fully developed character returns back to the Creator, the Khaliq.
So character is the real earning and the real acquisition of the soul.
A soul that returns back to its master without a developed character is an impoverished soul.
When the body is weak, it
cannot benefit from the offerings of this world.
And when a soul and a spirit is weak, when it lacks character, it is unable to enjoy the pleasures of the afterlife.
Islam, in its essence, is composed of two parts: worship and the development of character.
Aribada and Akhlaq.
This is why our Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam was sent to teach us and perfect our akhlaq.
That was his mission.
innama bwaistu lim makarimal akhlaq I was sent for no other reason.
innama is a very special usage in the Arabic language.
It emphasizes that whatever is being said, that's the only reason.
innama bwaistu lim makarimal akhlaq I was sent for nothing else
but to perfect human character now if you ask a Muslim what was the prophet's miracle the unanimous answer that you will get is always the Quran right the gift and the miracle indeed to the Arab was the Quran because the Ajam cannot understand the Quran the word in Arabic for a non-Arab is Ajam
which means dumb or mute.
Somebody who can't speak, like for instance, the Arabs say, right, the dumb animal.
And this is not just limited to Arabic, this applies to other languages as well.
For instance, the Greeks, right?
The word for a non-Greek for them was barbar, from which we get barbarian.
So for in Greek barber means the one who cannot speak.
There's similar there's a word for non Zulu, right?
They have the same thing.
So people when they look at other people of other languages and cannot understand them, they assume it must be like animals because you know, we can't understand the speech of animals.
But the Arabs.
When they considered non-Arabs as Ajam, as mute people, it was not out of an insult.
They had a very good reason for that.
Because they would go to a culture, for instance, they would go to a Persian and they would ask, How many words do you have for a lion?
And the Persians would say, We have one word, lion.
whatever in their language the word was for lion.
They would say, we have one word for lion.
And they would say, you have one word for lion?
We have over 350 words just for lion.
There are over 350 words in the ancient Arabic just for lion.
They would say, we have , which is a lion when it hunts at night.
We have , which is a short, strong lion.
We have qaswara, which is a lion when the animals are fleeing from it.
We have laith, which is a lion when, you know, they say ...
when a lion is circling its prey to attack it, that's laith.
They say we have oursama, which is a lion when it's leaping to attack.
so all of these words that the Arabs use just for a lion then there's Hamza which is the lion when he's roaring there is Shibal there is Warad there is Abbas which is used for the leader of the pack there's Haris there's Basil there is Duraam Ribal, Miyas, Gazamfar so many names just for a lion
So when they would hear the Persian say that we have only one word for a lion Right to them they were like ajam mute dumb So this is the way they would look at things Now if you sent a message to people and it's in Arabic And the miracle of Quran is truly Arabic.
There's no doubt about that, right?
The true Ajazal Quran
The true miracle of the Quran is absolutely in the linguistic perfection of Arabic.
And I did, I think over 10 sessions on this a few years ago, looking at the miracle of Quran from 10 different angles, linguistic angles.
So Arabic is no doubt about it, an incredible language.
Absolutely no doubt about it.
Ancient Arabic, not today's Arabic, not the dialectical Arabic, the original ancient Arabic.
But what does the non-Arab have?
How does the non-Arab come to know that Islam is indeed a revelation from God?
When we read the Quran in English or when we read it in Urdu, we have a difficult time understanding it because Quran is not a linear book, right?
In the Bible, the Bible, it starts with in the beginning.
right Bible starts with in the beginning that's how the Bible starts in the beginning the Quran starts with Alif lam mean what does that mean Alif lam mean we don't know what that means and then it says that is the book in which there is no doubt not this is the book in which there is no doubt that is the book so this is how Allah begins his book after Al-Fatiha
So for us as non-Arabs, it gets very confusing because these things can only be understood properly through Arabic linguistics or the Tawil or things like that.
But how does the Ajam, the non-Arab, come to understand these things?
How does the non-Arab know that this is the truth?
And the answer is look at how they became Muslim.
wherever they went wherever the Arabs went what was the factor that deciding factor that led to for these non-Arabs to become Muslim it wasn't the Ajazul Quran because they couldn't understand Arabic it was the Ajazul Akhlaq it was the Ajazul Khulq the miracle of character this was what struck the non-Arabs heart
and this is why the gift that Allah gave to the non Arabs to us is the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam this is why we see that all over the non Arab world we find this immense love in the hearts of people for the messenger why because of his beautiful character because of his high ethical standards Allah says in the Quran
I think it's surah al-nun wal kalam he begins that surah I think with with the verse in which he says Allah says to his messenger absolutely without a doubt you are committed to a high ethical standard a great ethical standard what many people don't realize is that this particular verse it was revealed
at a very early stage right after he was chosen as prophet this verse was revealed right at the beginning of his mission and what that suggests is that this verse is not referring to the Prophet's character as a prophet it's referring to his character as a person
as a member of that society for 40 years because there is yet the 23 years of his prophethood to unfold.
It hasn't happened yet.
This verse is coming right at the beginning which is showing that this praise is for his character as a person, not as a prophet.
It's referring to his character pre-Islam.
So he is this regular citizen of this community when God is praising his character.
Why?
You know, because you have, you can have great things to say, you know, as a preacher, even as a prophet, but a message is hollow in and of itself if it's not fortified by credibility.
And one of the most sustainable forms of credibility is character.
I mean, today you can have so many eloquent, well-spoken politicians, right?
We see that all the time.
But what's the easiest way to dismantle their entire political campaign?
Just smear their character, right?
If you can just find something that's a flaw in their character, some kind of corruption, then it doesn't matter how well they speak or how highly they speak of ideals.
None of it really matters at that point because there's no character to back up those high claims.
And so what's really incredible about this verse that Allah praising his character right at the beginning
Because Makkah pre-Islam was a horrible society.
We know that, right?
Makkah was like pretty gangster at that time.
They were corrupt in their business practices.
They were corrupt in their social practices.
There was inequality, injustice, law of the jungle.
The strong would beat up the weak just because they could, might was right.
This was the kind of society, this was the kind of lifestyle that they had.
And they had great economic promise and they had great economic strength.
So that's why they didn't feel the need to reform themselves.
Now, when there is one decent person living in an overwhelmingly corrupt society who sticks to his honesty, who sticks to his principle, how difficult do you think it is for that person to survive?
And yet, not only does he survive, he stands out so much from the rest.
Not because he was preaching anything.
As a matter of fact, if you read his Seerah, he's described as a quiet individual.
He was the quiet type originally.
But because of his business dealings with people, because of his honesty, because of his Akhlaq, he got named a Sadiq wal Amin.
In a culture where poetry was used to insult people,
In that culture, he earned the title as-Sadiq wal-Amin the truthful one and the trustworthy one.
And so in this verse, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he refers to that and he says to the people of Makkah, you're questioning the integrity of this man as a messenger?
When you've never questioned his integrity for 40 years as the most decent among you?
You who don't like to praise anyone
You who are obsessed with praising only yourselves, you have praised him.
So the ultimate testimony of his character is that even those who didn't really want to accept his message, they couldn't deny the vastness and the greatness of his character.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Allah describes his character as Rahmatul lil Alameen.
Wama ar salnaqa illa rahmatallila alameen We have only sent you as a Rahma, as a mercy to all mankind.
He was sent to honor human beings.
In this verse, Allah is describing him as mercy.
He's calling him Rahma.
He's not saying that the Prophet is merciful.
He's not saying he's someone manifesting an attribute.
No, he's saying he is the attribute himself.
Because he was extremely kind and extremely gentle by nature.
Malana Ali in one of his descriptions about the Prophet said he was the gentlest of people by disposition.
His khulq was layin.
He was soft by his nature.
And Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, he said, Al-mu'minu hayinun wa layinun.
The believer is soft and gentle by his nature.
When he was described by one of his Sahaba, he said, you know, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he didn't make things difficult for people.
Nor did he go out seeking faults in people, but instead he taught people and he made things easy for them.
So part of his character sallallahu alaihi wasallam was that he was sent for taisir for ease to human beings.
He was sent to make our lives easy.
He was sent to take out the akhlal the shackles and the chains of previous dispensations.
He came to set people free of the shackles of their own lower selves of their desire because desires oppress.
So he said, ba'astu bil hanafiyah samha I was sent with the forgiving and gentle hanafiyah way.
The Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, he said, May Allah have mercy.
Rahimallahu imra'an samha idha ba'awa idha shtarah May Allah have mercy on a man who is forgiving when he is buying or selling.
You know, he prayed for mercy for people like that.
You know, those who when they buy and they sell, they say, Khalas, you know, if the man has 10 dirhams and the item costs 12, take it.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about the two dirhams.
Or for the man buying the item, if the merchant doesn't have change, Khalas, take the dirham.
That's samaha.
So he taught people how to be forgiving.
I was sent with the tolerant way of the Hanif.
The Hanif is the person who inclines towards the truth or somebody who inclines towards righteousness.
So he is the greatest manifestation of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's mercy to humanity.
And one of the greatest gifts that our Prophet gave us is his Akhlaq, his character.
His greatest gift to us is not the Akam.
it's not the injunctions but how he lived those injunctions how he carried out those injunctions Allah says in the Quran that it is from Allah's mercy that he made you a mercy and if you were hard-hearted right
That if you were harsh, the word faz, you know, fazad means harshness in the self.
So Allah says if you were faz, or ghaliz al-qalb, the word ghaliz comes from the root ghiz, which means heaviness.
So if your heart was heavy, if it was weighty, then people would just disperse from around you.
And by nature, we do not like people to be harsh with us.
That's just a natural thing, right?
Aristotle said that the root cause of all enmity among human beings is that somebody feels slighted by another person.
The sense of Ihana, of being insulted.
But when it came to the prophet, they said his gathering was like, He gave everyone in his companions
A dew.
He fulfilled the dew if they had a dew coming.
He gave everybody his complete attention.
So much so that each one of them thought that he was the most important one in that gathering.
SubhanAllah.
Allahumma Salli Ala Muhammad Ali.
I mean, how amazing is that?
He was constantly gathered by companions and they say every companion says that he made them feel
that he was the most important, that he was the most beloved.
Can you imagine how difficult that is to do?
We go out in groups, right?
Can we do that?
He always preferred the best for the other person over him.
Always, there's a narration in which he had two sivak, right?
The sivak is the stick that is used for brushing teeth.
Even today in Middle East and Arab countries it's used.
So, you know, he had two sivak, two sticks and there was an Arabi, a Bedouin there.
And one of the sticks that he had was broken.
It had a crookedness in it.
And the other one was straight.
So he looked at the two and then he gave the Bedouin the straight one and he kept the crooked one for himself.
This is ithar, altruism.
And one of the scholars said that if this is his Isar for a simple Bedouin, who is a stranger and who doesn't even care if it's crooked or straight, what about the rest of the people that he actually, that, you know, the people closest to the prophet.
So this was his nature, always deciding the better, the best for the other person.
We're the other way around.
I'll keep the best and give you the one, you know, I'll regift something to you.
I'm not gonna get you a gift that I would get for myself.
I'm just gonna save all the other gifts that people gave me and I'm just gonna wrap them up and give it to you.
That's me.
But the Prophet always preferred to give the better gift to the other person.
He was gentle in his teachings.
You know, one of them said to the Prophet , this man he was in prayer and somebody sneezed during prayer.
And at that point, keep in mind that these injunctions, they were still coming down and they all didn't know everything clearly.
So there's this gathering, people are doing prayers and somebody sneezed.
And this man who was in prayer, during the prayer, he said, may Allah have mercy on you, which is what we say when we hear somebody sneeze in Islam, right?
But the thing is he did that during the prayer and everybody lost it in the prayer.
which is what you would expect today anywhere, right?
Are you crazy?
So they all started striking their fist on their thighs, right?
Like this, trying to shut them up.
And so this poor man, he realized he did something wrong and he just became quiet.
He says, after the prayer, the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, he called him, Come over.
And the man says, I got really scared.
I thought he was gonna get angry with me because that was the Arab nature.
I thought he was gonna beat me.
He's gonna punish me.
So he said, he went to the Prophet all scared.
And the Prophet said to him, no, he said, he narrates this.
He says,
When I went to the Prophet, Ma kaharani, wala dharabani, wala shatamani.
He didn't look at me in a harsh way.
He didn't say anything mean to me.
He didn't strike me or hit me.
Instead, he said to me, Inna haadhis salah.
Look, this is our prayer.
Wala yas lahu fiha shayan min kalamin nass.
Inna mahiyat tasbihun wa tahadidun wa takbirun.
He said this is our prayer to Allah and it is not right for us to talk amongst ourselves during our prayer because we're speaking to God.
Prayer is meant to praise the Lord, to remember him, to elevate his name.
I mean, how do we behave?
I mean, this is the sad part, right?
When you look into this mirror, so we don't look good, do we?
The man said, Wallahi ya RasulAllah.
He said, Ya RasulAllah, I have never seen anyone teach like this to me before or after.
Look how we teach our children, right?
Scolding, yelling, beating.
He was gentle, he was loving in his teaching mechanisms.
You know, one man came to the Prophet
He said, Ya Rasulullah, everything in Islam makes sense to me except for one thing.
He said, I love women.
He loved women.
He wanted to go and sleep with whoever he wanted.
So he said, you know, he came to the Prophet, he said, Ya Rasulullah, I want to become Muslim, but I love Zina.
I love fornication.
Allahu Akbar.
Go and try saying this to anyone in authority today.
I challenge you go and try to say this go to try anybody in authority go and tell them you love Zina and see what he says can you even imagine that this is the prophet of Allah this man is saying this to no other than Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam so he said to the prophet ya Rasulullah I love Zina the prophet said to him do you have a sister
He said yes.
He said would you like somebody to go and sleep with your sister?
He said Hasha never.
He said do you have an aunt?
He said yes.
He said would you like somebody to sleep with your aunt without haq?
He said Hasha never.
Do you have a mother?
He said yes.
Would you like somebody to do that to your mother?
The man said no.
He said the woman that you want to sleep with they are either somebody's sister or somebody's aunt or somebody's mother.
Is that right for you to put them through that for your own pleasures?
SubhanAllah the man said wallahi I went in the company of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam with a love for sleeping with women more than anything without taking the responsibility.
He said I walked out of there and it was the most detestable thing to me.
SubhanAllah
This was his way in changing people.
This is how he transformed people.
The most, the worst.
Today we ask a question that is inappropriate.
It's like, how dare you?
You're going to hell.
Shame on you.
We make people feel miserable for just a question they want to know about.
He told jokes.
You know, his wives in the Seerah, they've said that he was always joking with us in the house.
He was lighthearted.
You know, the Prophet, he said, I joke, but I never tell lies in my joke.
I always speak the truth.
A man came to the Prophet and he said, let me borrow a camel.
And the Prophet said, I'll give you the baby of a she camel.
and he said what would that benefit me right a baby of a she-camel because he wanted to ride it Prophet said isn't every camel the baby of a she-camel right just light-hearted conversation but truth another time an old lady came up to him and said am I going to go to Jannah?
she was an old lady he said
He said, old women do not go to paradise.
And she became sad.
And then he laughed and he said, you will go in young and beautiful.
And then she was happy.
He was a merciful man.
He was a forgiving man.
A man came to the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and said, Ya Rasulallah, Halatu Halatu, O messenger of Allah, I have destroyed myself.
He said what did you do?
He says, I slept with my wife in the daytime in Ramadan and the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, What made you do that?
He said, Ya Rasulallah.
he said you know I saw my wife in the light of the moon in the moonlight and I just couldn't help myself he laughed at the man he said don't worry go do the expiation go free a slave he said ya Rasulullah I don't have any possessions okay no problem go fast two months the man said ya Rasulullah
I can't do that I mean in Ramadan I'm having trouble he said I can't even do the fast of Ramadan you're telling me to do two months he said no problem get some dates go feed 60 people he said ya Rasulullah I don't have any money I have nothing to buy dates with he told somebody bring some dates he gave those dates to that man he said go give it to people the man said ya Rasulullah do they have to be poor
He said, yes, they have to be for Qura.
He said, Ya Rasulullah, no one's more poor than me and my own family in my tribe.
So he said, go and eat it with your family.
Go feed your family.
Ease.
He was just constantly making things easy for people.
This was his nature.
This was his character.
You know, even when people came to him full of sin, Musniboon, this man, he was in a state of sin.
But the Prophet was showing his humanity by letting this man feel Baba Rahmatullahi Wasir.
He was just letting the man know that you're a human being.
You made a mistake.
It's okay.
That's what he did with people.
He made them realize that the doors of Allah's mercy are wide open.
That's all he ever did.
I mean this is why you know to make people despair from the mercy of Allah these are evil people I'm telling you who do this I don't care who that person is if he turns you towards despair and hopelessness in Allah's mercy that is an evil person in my book I don't care how many times he prays a day I don't care how much he fasts
That is not the character of my prophet.
You know there's a Haditha Qudsi in which prophet says that Allah you know whoever says that Allah will not forgive you he will send that person to hell.
Don't judge people.
Don't tell people that you know where Allah's mercy is or where his Baraka is.
Don't do that really.
I mean who do we think we are?
we don't know anything nothing we have absolutely no knowledge about Allah do not elevate yourself over Allah we do not know who is going where I don't even know where I'm going I certainly cannot assume where you are going or where other people are going when I don't even know where I'm going
Right?
So we have big hopes in Allah no doubt about it, right?
Allah's mercy is vast and we have high expectations from our Lord just as Allah has high hopes with us.
We have high hopes with Allah on the day of judgment.
And the Prophet was always calling people to Allah's mercy.
always inviting people to Allah's hope the worst of people there was this Bedouin who was a Jew and Bedouins if you know anything about Bedouins they're very rough people generally because they're uncultured they live their entire lives in desert so there was this Jewish Bedouin who absolutely hated the Prophet and he hated Islam
And he was so extreme in his hatred that he was willing to die for it.
Imagine that.
So one day the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam was sitting with a Sahaba in his mosque and this guy walks in, he goes to a corner and he begins urinating in the Masjid.
Keep in mind, this is Masjid and Nabu we were talking about, right?
The second most esteemed and honored place for a Muslim after the Kaaba.
And he knows he knows that the companions would what they would do to him.
He knew they were going to kill him for this.
And he does that still.
So imagine the psychological state of this man, the hatred in his heart for the Prophet and Islam that he was willing to die for his hate.
What would you do?
Seriously, what would you do if someone walks into your living room and starts urinating?
I mean, think about it, seriously.
Put yourself in his shoes.
How would you behave?
So naturally, the Sahaba, they pulled out their swords.
They were furious.
They were ready to kill this guy for his insolent behavior and for disrespecting the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and the sanctified Masjid.
And the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, he stopped them.
He said, wait, let him finish.
This is the character of Rasulullah because you know we know that it's very painful to stop once you start urinating.
So he said to them wait let him finish and then once he was done he asked his companions to go wash the place with water and then he went up to this man and he said brother every human being needs to urinate.
We all as human beings have that need within us but this place is not made for that.
This place is made for worship of Allah .
He says that Jew he said these kind words of Rasulullah he said transformed my entire life.
He couldn't believe it.
He was expecting to be chopped to pieces.
That's what he wanted.
And here there is this man displaying the most extreme form of love and mercy.
So the man, he says to the Prophet, Ashadu an laa ilaha illallah wa ashadu anna ka rasulullah I testify that there is no God but Allah and you indeed are his messenger.
This was our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam.
And then the man says, Fida abi wa ummi bika ya rasulullah May my mother and my father be ransomed for you.
I walked in here with hatred in my heart for you and your religion.
And now I'm going to walk out of this place with nothing but love and respect in my heart.
And I, he said, I swear to you, I will not show you my inauspicious face again until I convert every single member in my tribe to Islam.
This is how he taught people with his character, with his Akhlaq.
He was gentle, he was kind, he was merciful.
He was always reflecting.
He didn't take rest like other people.
He was always concerned about his Ummah, his nation.
He never spoke about anything that was unnecessary.
He had long periods of silence.
He used to open and close his words with a full expression.
He spoke with comprehensive words.
He never said anything in excess.
And he was never at a loss for words.
And his character was such that when he walked among people, he would just stop and he would talk.
You know, he would ask people, how are you doing?
He wanted to genuinely know their states.
They said that in his description, they said that when he spoke to someone, he gave them his full face.
You know, he didn't listen to them while they were talking to his side.
He would literally turn around and face them when he would listen to them.
He would give them his entire being, sallallahu alaihi wa sallam.
This is tarbiya, this is education.
That's all he was doing, teaching people how to listen.
He never interrupted anyone while they were speaking, no matter how long they spoke.
How long do we listen before we interrupt?
We have no listening skills today.
We zone out, we tune out.
And if we do listen, we listen to respond.
We don't listen when someone's really talking to us, right?
Most people are just preparing a response while the other person is talking.
We don't empathize.
We're just listening to give advice.
So in his character is such an amazing lesson for all of us to learn.
He was kind and loving to children.
He once visited the house of Anas ibn Malik, who had a little brother.
His name was Abu Amer.
You know, his father got him a little bird that he used to play with.
They used to call it Nugar.
It's a small little bird.
So once he came over and he saw Abu Amer was sad.
So he asked his parents, what's troubling him?
Look at that, right?
He's coming to visit the family.
and he sees one member of the family, this child is depressed.
We go into the houses of people and we're not even aware of their states, of people around us.
We don't read expressions.
He walked in, he looked and saw that this little boy is depressed.
He asked the parents, what's troubling him?
They said, his little bird died.
So the Prophet went up to him, sat next to him,
Oh Abu Amair, what happened to your little bird?
I mean, he's a little child that just lost a bird.
He's the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam sent to guide humanity.
Why does he need to sit with this little kid?
No, he sits with him, consoles him, spends time with him till the boy is happy.
Subhanallah, he teaches him about death.
He teaches him the lesson that everything in this world is going to die.
And he's in a better place.
He's with Allah.
He makes the child happy.
He speaks to him at his level.
He loved children.
He honored them.
You know, once he was walking with Imam Hussain riding on his shoulder and a man saw it and he said to Imam Hussain, he said, Naamul Marqab, what an excellent vehicle you have.
Because he was riding the shoulder of the Prophet, Marqab is what you ride on.
So he said, What an excellent riding vehicle you have.
And the Prophet said, .
And he said, Also, what an excellent rider.
Look at that, right?
This is Tashrif honoring the child, giving him importance.
This is what the Prophet did.
We're like, shut up.
Don't interrupt while we're talking, adults talking here, get lost.
SubhanAllah, he made everyone feel important.
He gave them importance.
This is nurturing the soul.
You know, because Allah, he looked at the soul.
He looked at everyone as a human being.
Look how we treat our servants, people of less stature, right?
RasulAllah always saw human beings.
He didn't see race, he didn't see creed, he didn't see religion, he didn't see color.
He just saw human beings because and for him every human being has importance.
In Allah's eyes, no one is insignificant.
Malana Ali he says, what is that?
That famous Dawa uka fiqa wa maa tashuru wa da uka minka wa maa tanzuru wa tahsabu anka inda wa tahsabu anna ka jirmun sagir
Wa fiqan tawil aalam al akbaru.
Wa antal kitabul mubeen allathi be ahrufihi yaz harul mudmaru.
What a beautiful, your cure is within your own self.
Your cure is within yourself but you don't realize it.
Your sorrows are from your own actions but you don't see it.
Wa tahisabu anna ka jirmun sagirun wa fi kaan tawil aalam al akbaru You think you're insignificant?
You have an entire universe operating within you.
Look at the structure of human being.
Look at the complexity of a human being.
Look at the DNA.
Wa antal kitabul mubeen alladhi bi oharfuhub yozharal mutumeru You are the clear book of Allah, every word of which is revealing Allah's secret.
do you think human being has been created in vain just came out from evolution that he doesn't have import he's just ashes to ashes dust to dust you think the human being doesn't have importance so in the eyes of the Prophet a human being was important and a human being in submission is even more precious
Rasulullah he said killing a believer unjustly is more atrocious with Allah than destroying the entire Kaaba brick by brick.
Human beings are important they're not insignificant and this is what he was letting people know like his concern for people.
And he honored everyone, irrespective of their color, creed, race.
That didn't matter to him.
His company was constant education.
They used to say, .
If we came upon him suddenly, we would go in a state of awe.
.
But when we were sitting with him in his company, spending time with him, we fell in love with him.
And this is not just for the Muslims, right?
Because we know that the emperor of Kisra, of Persia, used to send messengers to the Prophet.
And these messengers, they said that when they came in the presence of the Prophet, they felt more awe than they did in the palaces of Kisra.
So when you look at the character of this man, you have to fall in love with him.
A scholar said that if the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam had no other miracle,
than the men and women he produced, that would be enough as his miracle.
If he had no other miracle, not the Quran, nothing else, but just the men and women that he produced through his Akhlaq, through his character, that is enough as a miracle.
He took simple, primitive people.
He turned them into the greatest thinkers, people are willing to die for him, the greatest people of Adab, of erudition,
You know, people of culture.
They weren't scholars.
They weren't aristocrats, you know, with these great backgrounds and formal education.
No.
Simple, simple people.
Hazrat Bilal Habshi, he becomes a giant among men.
And he was an Abyssinian slave.
Allahu Akbar.
You know, my Hala, just a few days ago, Anisa Hala, she shared the story of Hazrat Bilal with me and
And I looked it up and incredible story.
So the story goes that they asked Bilal, How did you meet the Prophet for the first time?
So he says, One day I was very sick and I was lying in bed and my master saw it as laziness and it made him angry.
So he dragged me and Hazrat Bilal had a really cruel master.
And so he said it made him angry.
So he dragged me out in the cold of the night while he's sick, right?
Keep in mind he's sick.
He has a high fever.
He drags him out in the cold of the night and makes him take his shirt off as a punishment for not being at work.
So Bilal says that, you know, he told me to get to work to grind the sack of wheat.
So he said, I started crying.
You know, and this a man walked up to me and asked me, why are you crying?
He didn't know that this was the messenger of Allah.
He just thought it was another man.
He's a slave.
Bilal said, I'm sick, I can barely walk and my master has given me these sacks of wheat to grind and if I don't do it by morning, he's going to beat me.
So the Prophet got up and he left and Bilal says, I thought in my heart, all these people they come and they want to know about my pain but nobody is willing to help.
And he says, As I was thinking this, this man returns to me with warm milk in one hand and some medicine in another.
And Bilal says, he gave it to me and he told me to go to bed.
And he said, I can't do that.
You know, if I'm not done grinding this wheat into flour, I'm gonna get beaten in the morning.
Prophet said, don't worry about it.
So Bilal said, I saw the Prophet grind the wheat all night while I slept and rested.
And then he again returned the next night with milk and medicine and did the same thing again.
He spent all night grinding the wheat for Bilal while he slept and rested.
Bilal says he did this for three consecutive nights until I regained my health.
Abyssinian slave.
Why does he have, what benefit is he getting out of doing that?
But this was our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and the love it generated in Bilal's heart after that.
So just look how he took these
less than ordinary people and he turned them into these Giants Abu Zar Ghaffari he was a Bedouin he belonged to Bani Ghaffar these guys were brigands they used to rob highways that's the tribe he belonged to and and this was the tribe that wrote the book on vengeance you know nobody messed with the with the Bani Ghaffar that is the tribe he was from they were ruthless people
And look at Abu Zarrafari.
He becomes one of the greatest companions and scholars of Rasulullah, of Malana Ali.
SubhanAllah.
Look at Abdullah ibn Mas'ud.
Look at this man.
He was a shepherd in the hills of Mecca.
A shepherd.
Go look at a shepherd.
Have you ever met a shepherd?
Seriously.
Simple people.
Not scholars.
No big ideas really.
They're very simple people.
They don't think about a whole lot.
Ibn Masrud, a shepherd, he becomes a teacher of an entire generation.
He teaches an entire...
75% of Hadiths and the meanings of those are from Abdullah Ibn Masrud.
An entire generation of Muslims come from the school, the madrasa of Ibn Masrud who came from the madrasa of the Prophet, just Akhlaq, just character, just the company of the Prophet.
I mean I can go on and on about the stories just telling you about the character of a prophet but you know I'm gonna end with this one last thing about him that I want to share with you that sums up his character for me at least of how he was prophesized in earlier books.
The advent of the prophet that he was going to come was mentioned in previous all previous religious books.
But so I want to share that how he was described, but I'm not going to translate it for you for the want of time.
But you know, there is this in these previous books, Allah.
describes all of his qualities by which he will be recognized or by which we can, you know, he was telling the Christians, the Jews, how you can recognize him.
And he said, so it goes like something like, ...
So those of you who knows Arabic, they can probably follow that.
You know, I'm gonna raise a man from amongst you.
...
wal hekmata mante kahu, was sit ka wal wafa'ar tabi'atahu, wal akwa wal ma'arufa huluku, wal haq asharia tuhu, wal adlasira tuhu, wal hadiyu imamu hu, wal Islamu milla tuhu, wa Ahmad Ismu hu, ahadibihi baadal dalala, wa aalamu bhi baadal jahala, wa arfa'u bhi baadal khamala, wa uarifu bhi baadal nakira, wa akfaru bhi baadal killa,
Wa aghna bhi baadal aila.
Wa ajmao bhi baadal fuqa.
Wa u'alifu bhi baina umaman muta farrika.
Wa qulubin mukhtalifa.
Wa ahwaun muta shattata.
Beautiful, beautiful wordings.
I mean, we could just, it's gonna take so much time to even explain this, but just describing these incredible qualities of the Prophet.
But after he revealed all of these beautiful characteristics,
and the qualities of the messenger, who's going to be sent for humanity so that nations could identify him.
After mentioning all this, in the end he says, he identifies the most prominent character of this man.
It says, You will see that this man will walk with such humility
the greatest man in the world the beloved of Allah the leader of all messengers that you will see him walk with such humility that if he walked on dry leaves you would not hear them crack under his feet to me this sums up the
the character of my prophet.
This humility, the sense of Abu Diya before Allah.
Seeing people as the creation of Allah.
May Allah strengthen us all, our children, our generation, you know, with the character of this incredible prophet.
He is such a school.
We have so much to learn from him.
You know, today is his birthday.
Today is the day we were blessed with his presence.
This day is not so that we just talk about all of this and forget about it the next day.
This 12th Rabbi al-Awl is not to be celebrated on one day.
It is meant to be celebrated every single day of our lives.
And the way we celebrate our messenger is by exemplifying his character, by cultivating
His character within our own self.
By constantly thinking, How would my Prophet interact here?
By knowing about him, by learning about him, by studying his interactions.
How did he deal with this situation?
What did he do?
What did he say in this situation?
That's celebrating the Prophet.
This day, this 12th Rabbil Abal is supposed to be celebrated every single day of our life.
It's not just, you know, we say all this good stuff about him and then just go on with our lives as it was.
That's not celebrating.
We can celebrate the rest of the world like this, not our Prophet.
We should celebrate him every single day of our lives by remembering him, by knowing about him, by learning about him.
...........................